so now I can say let's keep on you sort
of like digging details out of this
graph it says find its maximum height
above the ground and the time to reach
this height did you go ahead and work
out where the vertex was I kind of think
you had to if you're going to graph it
in a reasonable way
so this spot here we can take advantage
of the symmetry of a parabola right the
axis of symmetry is going to be halfway
between the roots which is true even
when you don't have roots or at least
not real ones so I've got time to being
the spot at which I've reached my
maximum height I'm interested in
displacement which is which are the
functions which function it's the first
one which is X right so I'm going to say
X using function notation again at time
two and you can plug it in and hopefully
you get well let's see here
40 minus five times two squared which is
why in fact I actually had to work this
out beforehand so that I knew this graph
would be reasonably accurate okay right
so have I answered the question at this
point I just need to have some units on
there because it's not centimeters it's
not kilometers its meters why the
acceleration at the top of the flight so
the top of the flight is that point we
just bothered finding just there right
find the acceleration at the top of the
flight we'll have a look at your
acceleration graph what's acceleration
doing it doesn't change ever it's
constant right so no didn't matter
whether you asked whether it was at the
top of the flight or at the bottom or
when it hits the ground the acceleration
is always negative ten meters right so
Part D because this question is in words
I'd like to say the acceleration in
words is have a look like I had earlier
right I can say it's accelerating
downwards at now I haven't talked about
this yet but we just talked about the
units of displacement the units are
velocity what are the units of
acceleration hmm
so whoops negative my length unit is
going to be meters that hasn't changed
but remember I'm going to go back to it
right here remember acceleration we find
that by oh I froze it sorry thank you
there we go
we found acceleration by differentiating
with respect to time a second time right
on a second occasion so therefore our
time unit is not just going to be per
second it's going to be per second per
second in fact that's sometimes the way
people say it meters per second per
second that's a little bit awkward and
harder to write so people will say per
second squared right you will also see
this written being that this per right
it's division it's a fraction after all
you will also see this written as
negative 10 meters per second they do
too right because that they mean the
same thing it's just using index
notation okay so you're going to have to
get used to seeing that and recognizing
or accordingly up the top here how could
I write velocity instead of using that
notation
yeah it's 20 meters per second and
that's how I write the per part of it
okay because that just means take the
fraction part yes mrs. Lee's oh yeah I
don't actually cuz I thank you I
describe direction using words so I
don't need to put the negative sign
because then I give the sign it's yeah
exactly
it's yeah good Paul so are you okay with
that I've described the direction I've
described as magnitude that's all I need
for a vector what was the question is
there a question attached to that Oh sir
we've established that acceleration is
not changing at any given point it's
always downwards at 10 meters per second
per second okay so how can it be that at
that point you're not going anywhere
because velocity is zero at this point
right in fact what do we call the toy
like this when we first introduced
geometrical applications of calculus
what do we call this ball like that
we call it a stationary point because
that's literally what the ball is doing
it is stationary at that moment okay
acceleration is nonzero
but that doesn't mean velocity can't be
zero yeah because in fact they are two
completely different graphs does that
make sense so there's no reason why you
can't have velocity being zero while
acceleration is something other than
that okay
in fact you actually have a look at what
the velocity is doing right here it is
going downward it's changing sign form
positive if you're moving upwards to
negative now you're moving downwards but
acceleration this entire time has always
been downwards it's always been when we
talked about gravity before right and
that doesn't change at least while we're
standing on the surface of yeah all
right we are to the last part right
party when is the ball height 50 meters
and what are its velocities then so you
can kind of tell by the way they've
given you this plural language within
the question that there's not one but
two spots where this happens and you
have a look at your graph you might like
to put an extra bit on here West fifteen
me somewhere like you loop so here are
my two spots right I'm expecting one
before time two and one after time two
so how do I find how do I solve this
question how do I actually yeah look at
those locations well if what I know
about this is its when displacement is
15 then the place I'm going to go in all
our equations is the displacement
equation right you've got so many
equations flying around a big part of
how you're solving this question is
working out which one you actually need
so I want to say there's the
displacement equation and I'm interested
when that is equal to a good question 15
thank you it's just a quadratic
I might rearrange this and divide make
it a little simpler so I think I can do
this
can someone go ahead in fact I saw we
oops what am i doing that's a tea like
there that's it I got my numbers
switched around Tara yeah that's which
science I did too many things you want
to go
can someone factorize told me now that
we had the right equation now when you
factorize this you do your sense check
and does it look like what your graph is
telling you looks pretty good right
remember we said we're expecting your
time before two at a time after two
bingo
that looks pretty good if you drew your
graph of reasonable accuracy then you
would confirm that as well so I've got
time one or three have I answered the
question at this point I need to find
the velocities at these times right so
I'm just going to say v1 and v3 you go
ahead and you can work them up there's
my equation there what you get 10
negative 10 so I need units on these
right because I've said it's a velocity
in fact I need units on all these time
one second and this is meters per second
by the way do you notice the symmetry
again right we noticed this at ball
launched and at ball landing we saw this
symmetry here why do you think we have
the same symmetry when we have a look at
when we're at height 15 anything's going
on
what was a very first line that we wrote
when we have a look at this thing it was
about displacement and we identified hey
it's a quadratic equation one of the
reasons why quadratic equations are so
fun and easy to work with it is because
of this symmetry that they have right
this is why when we look in projectile
motion this would become really
important later on when you take
advantage of the symmetry of the
situation if you have a look at any you
can try any displacement that you like
try a displacement one or two or three
or four anything up to 20 right and you
will get the same kind of pattern
observed